ted lasso has been nominated for an
insane
20 emmy awards and this man joining us
here on the rich eisen show co-creator
writer of this program and also
nominated for an emmy for best
supporting actor
on the program brendan hunt how are you
brendan i'm all right rich how are you
i'm doing well congratulations on
everything going on with this program
yeah thanks man it's nuts well that's
definitely one way to
describe it um so it's it's been well
established that this was
based on something you guys did for nbc
sports
as i guess a one-off walk me through how
um we go from that to 20 emmy awards
and hopefully some trophies in the case
for you
um yeah i mean you're right it was 100 a
one-off you know i got a i got a call
from jason
um you know i've known for years from
chicago improv days and um
like hey nbc sports wants me to do a
soccer thing and he and i
both became soccer fans to different
degrees at around the same time living
in amsterdam
neither one of us was into soccer you
know as kids in the midwest
um but we moved to europe and caught the
bug
so he calls me there's a soccer thing
and like if we if we do it we get to go
to england for three whole days
oh three whole days um and then they
gotta fly us out
to uh to go see a premier league game
later when the season starts
oh great this is the best gig ever it
will never get better
than three days in london and one soccer
game um
but it did uh because yeah they they
they really liked it apparently it did
very well for them and so they had us
come back to another one the next year
and by that point then we were really
starting to like it like this is
just flat out fun to do you know and
jason really
clearly loves his character at that
point it was me and jason and our buddy
joe kelly was the other creator of the
show
and um and we just wanted to find a way
to keep doing it so like
we threw together you know we met at
jason's place in brooklyn for a week and
we threw together like a
uh an outline for a season at that point
we were looking at it like
like the original office basically so
like two six episode seasons and a movie
right special right and you know we
wrote we wrote a pilot i'm like okay
well let's see
let's see what happens here and then
nothing happened nothing happened for a
very long time
until bill lawrence came along uh to
join the creator crew
and uh once bill lawrence is involved oh
things start moving
and um and within gosh i don't know four
months after that we had a writer's room
going and
six months after that we were in london
again for substantially longer than
three days
which premier league match did you see
that time oh that time
we um i'm an arsenal fan okay and i'm
kind of the biggest
uh soccer fan of the three of us who
originally went so they kind of let me
tip the scales um and i convinced them
that going to see arsenal at tottenham
would be a particularly good game to go
see
um you know with the calendar we had
available and we sat
in the uh in the tottenham director's
box and like
you know i'm an arsenal fan but i'm also
a good guest so like you know you wear a
suit
yeah respectable okay um and like i knew
like if there's a score there's tension
i'm gonna keep it together
and and then arsenal score on a
breakaway and i believe
literally the first minute and uh i
don't know
if this is gonna be a video interview
for for your folks but my
reaction was was literally
you couldn't say you're good too you're
too good
i couldn't it was a great goal and then
the game finished one nothing it was
just one goal at the beginning so
for the neutrals i.e my friends who came
with the worst
game you could see because the crowd
never really got into it but
i had the time in my life and now that
stadium has been torn down so
we we saw you know a wee piece of
history
i called an nfl game um
two years ago pre-covered uh in the new
tottenham hotspur
stadium i was there oh so you were there
for that one so the buccaneers the tampa
bay buccaneers were
were there there were a couple of them
there i was the one calling the
buccaneers
were there and the reason why i bring it
up is because
i was told by the locals that
arsenal fans were very giddy
over the fact that the buccaneers were
the home team in tottenham because
the buccaneers and arsenal share the
same team colors
and thus arsenal's team colors were all
over
tottenham hot spurs stadium which made
tottenham fans thoroughly sick to their
stomachs
and they loved that they absolutely
loved that the game i had gone to in
that same run
which was like a great historical sports
day for me because like there was an
arsenal game that day that i got to go
to
right and then a bears game uh and i'm
from chicago so
i've seen an arsenal game and a bears
game that were neither exhibition games
in the same city on the same day the
bears lost that game
but uh at the new town stadium which is
a great stadium gotta say
yes um and you know as you know like
these
nfl uh london games get all the nfl fans
from all around
europe yes uh and they're all big uh
soccer fans and a lot of them are
germans so
they come to the stadium and harry kane
hero of tottenham hotspur
a huge nfl fan like has aspirations of
being a kicker someday a place kicker
okay um uh he comes out to give the
honorary coin toss
and in his own stadium is booed
lustily by 95
of the crowd and the bears lost that day
and that sucked but
harry kane bless him getting booed was a
was a beautiful beautiful thing
if i'm not mistaken the bears need to
just lose they lost in some
gut-wrenching fashion as well brandon
raiders like
came out hot and and they got up by like
20
right uh like it was a coming out party
for joseph
and uh that's his name right the running
back i got his initials of jj
yes yeah i know yeah jacobs it was
jacobs
yeah killed it yeah he was he was
amazing and the bears you know
fought valiantly-ish to try to come back
and they and they did not
brennan hunt here on the rich eisen show
the emmy award
uh nominated actor and writer man who
plays coach beard on ted lasso here
on the rich eisen show where does the um
the warmth of this show come from what
is the walk me through
how you would create a show and you're
like okay this guy
and everyone around him has got to have
the sensibility
to warm and be
you know very sweethearted
uh what where where did that come from
that you would emphasize that because i
think that's part of the reason why your
show is such a smash hit not just the
comedy
and the characters but there's just a
warmth that i think people are attracted
to
brendan yeah i think it's it comes you
know from
you know a little uh a lot from kansas
in kansas city where jason's from it
comes a little from
chicago where i'm from and also central
illinois like
normal bloomington uh where i went to
school and a little bit from uh
marietta georgia where joe kelly's from
like we're all
you know marietta georgia is not quite
the midwest as much as the other two but
you know
joe's got a real like yeah i don't know
how to phrase this correctly but like
you know a good southern sensibility
you know um and uh and he lived in
chicago for a long time too and
there's just it all adds up to a very
midwestern
kind of vibe in the show like we weren't
necessarily
going out of our way to make someone
fred rogers-like
like we were we were drawing from our
own
experience you know um jason's drawing
from his dad jason's drawings from from
coaches he had
joe also had coaches he liked i was not
not so athletic i didn't have any
coaches per se
but you know the odd theater teacher and
uh and like my bosses at the uh
at the auditorium where i was a you know
a stagehand for a while like
just sturdy midwestern
listeners um so we were just modeling
people that we've known all our lives
and putting them into this character you
know we weren't we weren't drawing from
some crazy fantasy land of kindness like
we were drawing from something that
exists
well because again it is it's just so
everybody's so vulnerable on the show
and then again it's
very funny and you put it all together
and it's
unlike anything that's on television
right now and the the show that
one one of the shows you're nominated
for for writing
called make rebecca great again talking
about the owner of the team i'll be
honest with you i
you know i don't mean to you know
embarrass you or anything like that but
i i turned to my wife when that episode
was over i said that
that was the greatest half hour of
television i think i've ever seen it was
beautiful it was funny it was sad it was
uh fun as well amazing
i really really was and i just there's
no question i just
like congratulations i mean you know
that's amazing truly is
beautiful and funny awesome it is
together it is one of my favorite
episodes
uh you know for without you know no no
spoiler shows we haven't seen it yet but
also hey catch up people
um but nick mohammed's locker room
speech
is absolutely one of my favorite moments
of the season um
you know jason and hannah do incredible
stuff that episode and like the
directing is really really good and the
editing is really good
and that closing song that plays right
the whole like it's uh you know
sometimes you show you just get like the
right part of a song but i believe
that's the entire
song you know it's strange by celeste
and it's
it just it just brings the whole thing
together and makes it more than some of
its parts and so
anyway i'm a fan that episode two so
thank you
and and season two available uh every
friday on
on apple plus where you can watch um ted
lasso
so there's no coaching inspiration for
your character
specifically anything something i mean
coaching-wise
no i mean you know i mean acting coaches
like you know one of my um
a couple of my professors uh down at
illinois state and
you know actually i just realized this
yesterday
the the his clearest analog is actually
a guy i worked with
at this student auditorium so in the
student center called the bone
student center in illinois state which
they may have renamed it i hope not we
all loved working at the boner
um but uh had braden auditorium and then
redbird arena
which became the new basketball arena
for uh uh
for isu but there was a guy named uh
matt hartley and matt hartley was just
the
i mean to this day in all my travels
around the world
and through all the halls of comedy the
most deadpan
person i've ever met um in my
entire life um and he was
he was the assistant to you know kind of
a rotating cast of
of bosses and he just stood in the back
and he waited
and uh said his piece it it was a tiny
bomb
every time uh you know good bomb and
then
off he went the only real example which
i can remember it being like um
you know like the first meeting uh you
know of the of the school year where you
all get your
your radios and um and you know john the
boss at that time
at a particular meeting like hands your
radio he gives a whole speech about what
it means to have a radio
and then and we're all you know
midwestern folk
matt harley just sits in the back and
just waits for a gap and says it's your
nomenclature
it sounds like a line from your show
i'll be honest with you it does sound
like something from ted lasso
you know i had to look it up like i
thought i was fairly well reasoned but
no
no my man from the prairie was out
vocabularying me
hard i love it fantastic so uh brendan
hunt couple more minutes left here on
the rich eisen show
with the emmy award-nominated actor and
writer and co-creator of ted lasso here
on the rich eisen show
what's your favorite line which one is
your your favorite where you're like
okay
you know you wrote it and then it was
executed
and now you've seen it and you're like
that's a good line like that's
which one's your favorite you gotta go
um i have a lot of favorites uh
uh only some of which i was involved in
the writing of okay but um
one of which one comes to mind is uh
episode nine you know rebecca has
something to say to ted and she invites
from her office
but she doesn't quite have the courage
to say what she wants to say yet
and and he senses that he's like are you
okay and she's like me i'm brilliant i'm
totally pops
this goes nuts with it yeah it's largely
her performance i'll give you
but her saying top of the pops that's it
huh interesting
i like that one it surprised so many
fans of the show that uh
the actress who plays rebecca is the
same one who was the
the nun from game of thrones who was uh
saying shame to queen cersei like people
can't that was really one of them
had nothing to do with your show but it
was one of the biggest reveals of season
one is that it was the same actress
you know when i learned that it made me
like it made me rethink
that character in game of thrones and
then and then her relationship
to uh to uh lena heady whatever her name
seriously
oh okay so it's not like the nun is not
some
you know wall of a woman under there
like no she too
is an amazon you know like was was she a
you know
sinning smoke show who had to be
converted now she's doing what had been
done to her
oh exactly i know if only queen cersei
had made the none biscuits
and given it to her every day could have
been a whole different relationship you
know what i mean
the whole time the whole walk of shame
so uh
congratulations on everything to you man
really
um uh i i i love the show it has
not lost a single step um in season two
and you know i it's funny how many
people were bringing up
um ted lasso when the super league was
created for a split
second and then it was gone in two days
and like how will ted lasso survive
you know and what would ted think about
all this and he'd be the one out there
kind of leading the fans to just
do the right thing i i i was honestly
thinking of your show
in the real life soccer stuff brandon
for real
you know in the middle of shooting it
when that came out as well is that right
were you thinking about what would hap
what would you have had to redo
something
would you were you thinking about that
first place yeah because we were
you know we were in the championship at
that time okay but it was going to have
a ripple effect on all the football for
sure but the the striking thing was like
we have a
a crew a fantastic crew that is you know
there's a lot of football fans in there
you know menu and spurs and arsenal and
they're all over the map
and oh the hatred for the european super
league
brought them together in such powerful
unanimity
isn't that amazing how that happened
oh man they hated it so much and it died
so fast like
let's get our 30 for 30 going on this
let's get our oral histories out
we're gonna need this it was it wasn't
even a three for three right you
couldn't even have done it
it was almost a thirty second or thirty
second uh well thanks
thanks for doing this man uh i'd love to
do this uh more often i'm a big fan of
your work
i'd like to keep talking with you um and
congrats and i hope you
win every last damn emmy that'll be
great well
thank you rach i mean correct me if i'm
wrong but this is the third decade
of my life uh in terms of the numbers in
the front of them in which
um i've been able to experience you oh
wow this is yeah
that's true i've been happy i i
appreciate you saying that man
and uh let's let's keep doing this more
often like i said thanks for the
thanks for doing this that's brendan
hunt right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here